thank you
[Music]
you are all gonna have a collective
groan when you hear this but we just
have to talk about it so China is
expecting a new wave of covid case
surges possibly reaching 65 million
infected by June which is now China with
the new variant called xbb can they
close their borders stop coming over
here you [__] Chinese
so good mayor of Orange County we can't
have another lockdown bro I am tired of
this lockdowns the mayor of Irvine you
got to be mayor Orange County have you
got your platform have you guys have you
guys seen
um there's been a lot of Chinese dudes
coming through Central and um like South
America oh yeah through the [__]
Mexico the so they're from China and
they go yeah easy way to get in yeah
just the Chinese guys no girls just all
men what's the deal with that
come up from the Bott I don't know I
mean the uh I mean like most immigrants
are coming here to work right and then
so like there was a guy that was
interviewing him and then the guys were
just like I like freedom I like America
I like freedom I want to see the I want
to see the the Liberty the Liberty the
Liberty I like that guy as opposed to
like the blue-haired chick in a [__]
college campus yeah saying what a piece
of [__] I am just because I'm a white
dude
you know her you are innately [__] I've
never met her one time my whole life and
she's like he likes to have sex with
women and he's a white guy and I'm like
oh my God racist
I'm like you know all of our ancestors
were dicks but okay yeah but then um The
Conspiracy side of it is that they're
sponsored by the Chinese government to
come out here and to start working but
they're um spy cells
so like they're slowly sending out folks
and if anything happens then boom
because then it's like the Chinese Farms
the the China is buying farmlands right
so they need to employ people they need
to build like that and then they're
saying like what's happening is that the
immigrants are coming in to work the
farms and all this stuff and they're
gonna be like
if we go to war with China boom they're
ready to be like Zoolander they'll play
a specific song and then they all just
cool
hey why is the China like Chinese why is
the China why is the China why is the
China no why why is the the fact that
Chinese are buying up Farmland a
conspiracy theory I just saw that
recently like oh it's okay it's not even
a conspiracy it's just a fact but like
no but it's being presented oh there's
like a groups who are saying this and
I'm like no it's literally it's true
yeah it is there's receipts indeed
that's right just buying taxes people
like to buy stuff yo they're just
wondering why I think the conspiracy
okay about the about the purchase is are
they setting up bases
legitimate businesses or what are they
doing I thought they were just setting
up for strangleholds for like to control
the food supply
so that's that's I think that's the
conspiracy which but it's not a
conference it's not a conspiracy that
they're purchasing the land though Fury
it seems like a very easy thing to
defend against or to remedy yeah but
it's not wow right what would you do
because a neck shark
they're the source that's what's
standing in the way the sympathy
the government literally goes all right
we're gonna we're gonna stop rapping but
look at these commenters we gotta do
something about next shark and you know
how I love commenting on next shark
I love seeing his
costume so funny dude so
um our great rep Judy Chu bought by the
CCP
um she was basically like promoting
blatant CCP talking point [__] right and
then I was like I am in disbelief that
they are all now bought and controlled
by this and people are like I can't
believe you're buying into the
xenophobia and I'm all like
do you think that the Chinese people and
the CCP are one like it's not it's not
one people it's not racist [__] too yeah
yeah it's one political group with a lot
of power and they have their own agenda
and now they're sponsoring our
politicians I would love if people just
imagined the ccps not Chinese and just a
body of people that are oh ruthlessly
gonna yeah view our unit party
government same way that's exactly yeah
that's like calling the Nazis like the
Germans of today it's like that was them
and that was that party it's like yeah
I don't know man but you know next chart
commenters are the one of the most
funniest people to like play with when
I'm that's one of my favorite part-times
pastimes thing part-time first time it's
pretty easy just to stir them up well
they're already so mad so wound up yeah
like they're just primed to disagree
they don't care what's being said it's
like no I just want to be the comment
that's opposite so everyone looks at me
no I think that to to their own
detriment they will fight for just
anyone who's Asian
so like let's say there's a [__] hey
the CCP is coming in and invading
California like if that's really
happening right yeah and then they'll be
like so what don't you want Asians why
is this news why is this news he goes so
what do you got against with the Chinese
and it's like so whites are being
invaded by Asians I think that's nice
good for them but they're very much
you're American you [__] face and it's
like they never know I'm Asian first
yeah and I'm like I'm Chinese American
yeah something like that did you spell
[__] face p-h-u-c so you have more
loyalty to the country that your parents
[__] ran away from
the commenters will be like he can't say
it they'll say the white guy can't say
it and also China Bots love neck shark
comments so they freaking yeah you can
just yeah we got a new [__] covet
stranger thing China like even as a
country they're not they're not reacting
to it the same way they used to they're
not gonna do like a crazy massive
um intense lockdown you're not gonna
lock it down to make the grandmas climb
out of the windows China China I guess
like their their approach now is is to
kind of coexist with it and just uh we
don't care anymore or like if you don't
care we don't care there's four new
vaccines that you need to get yeah
honestly yeah that too but also they
this is according I guess like this news
of them peaking 65 million cases it's
not news to them they knew this would
happen this is all part of the plan kind
of thing they're on target Millions It's
like because they know that it happens
in waves and they knew that when they
opened up from their initial lockdown
that they would have a surge so they're
just looking at it like oh no this is
okay we know this is gonna happen we're
gonna respond accordingly how do you
keep them inside
oh you just weld the door shut yeah
don't come over here that [__] went down
where um they were uh they weld the door
shut and then there was a fire and then
all the people couldn't get out of that
apartment damn that didn't happen I
didn't see that on weibo
you know what's crazy is it started a
whole movement in China yeah it was
crazy yeah that's [__] up what would
you guys do if there is another lockdown
dude I'm done bro I don't think I'd
follow I'm completely done I would do
the same thing I did before what's uh
live my normal life
the difference is you live in OC it's
L.A and OC was so different bro
everybody was everybody was in shock
they're like how are they getting away
with this like everybody was kind of mad
at least I was jealous I was running
during the lockdown what the [__] is ran
in the trail yeah people were pissed you
know what it was I was putting people in
danger on the trail bro what the [__]
run are you gonna say that on camera
yeah I'm gonna run in public it was but
the funniest thing was how divisive
things got when like you would post
something you were doing and like half
your friends would be like that's so
messed up you're doing that during the
time like this and then now they all
don't remember ever saying that no [__]
them dude I got
for riding in the back of a pickup
without a [__] mask on yeah
[__] so stupid bro
[__] is maybe the dumbest thing I've
ever seen
you know what's that people still wear
it now I know I every time I see it I
give people a stink eye like I've never
even like I forced stink I'm always like
I go hard on it I'm like it's not even
reasonable the amount of expressions
like like I'm like I don't have a
close-up look it's the camera's far away
like people that are driving in a car by
themselves windows up and I took a
picture of the guy this morning he's in
a he's in a convertible This Guy's in a
convertible and he looks like a [__]
GI Joe bad guy and I took a picture of
this [__] this morning
he looks like a maybe he just robbed the
bank it's California after all yeah and
he gave me the peace sign because but
yeah why is he doing this in a
convertible it makes no sense yeah he
wants air but not too much air hey but
low-key though you know as a former
convertible user
sometimes your face gets cold so that's
probably windows and uh turn on the
heater when the top is down dude
sometimes you get a little bit Uber
driver we're actually laughing so hard
we couldn't even [__] breathe you
thought this guy's such an idiot a ski
mask is a wild Choice it is why a ball
Club practically and then think about
the damage so like we did go through
lockdown to try to save lives and all
these things right but like how many
people die because of mental health
issues because of suicide because of
alcoholism because uh well everybody
went crazy
there's so many people that just what
what it's done to our society and
economy from those lockdown rules that
were so [__] stupid stupid not
informed by anything nothing just
jumping fear-mongering even the six feet
away thing they said they just made it
up but yeah we're like six feet sounds
pretty good because like you know like
you can't do three feet like that's just
too crazy so the six feet sounds pretty
good they literally just winged you know
what the funny thing is I think it was
science science they pulled back all the
vaccines and no one talks about that
they pulled it back they say now it's
dangerous now it's this and it's from
the [__] companies that administered
it
so I'm like dude what the [__] is
happening man
Kennedy 24 is happening don't worry Man
by the time uh xbb is here we'll have
all new vaccines so it's cool
they should have vaccines in gummy form
oh yeah more people take it remember but
you still gotta show them the door when
I when I got my vaccine they they tell
you and everyone experienced this when
they got their vaccine they tell you
wait in your car for 15 minutes
before you leave that's what I told you
yeah why because you can no no because
of the fainting yeah they had people
fainting yeah oh my God so then you're
sitting in you're as soon as you get it
you're like okay now I feel
uncomfortable this is the weirdest thing
ever and you're sitting in your car and
you're thinking for 15 minutes like did
I make a [__] mistake dude should I
have gotten this [__] vaccine because
you're like why are they making you wait
in your car 15 minutes like I've never
had to do this ever everyone felt that
way you didn't feel this way well then
your ears started to change yeah like
immediately yeah they injected into you
I started talking about the list and I
was like I don't know if this is a
vaccine or nothing
they're like you're gonna take the
vaccine wait 15 minutes before you put
your Beats by Dre back on I was like huh
that's the other thing that is crazy
about this [__] too right on the other
side like the everybody blaming
everything on the vaccine like every
time anybody dies like that guy got the
vaccine yeah what the [__] are you
talking about dude no everyone didn't
die the vaccine bro dude I [__] did
it I was blaming everything on the
vaccine did you blame your jaywalking
taking on the vaccine I wanted to yeah
oh dude I had the vaccine like my
brain's all like wait yeah I didn't know
where I was going officer there's lights
it's a lock don't walk which what is it
you know what I think one of the worst
things though that happened because of
that I feel like the government shot
themselves in the foot because I don't
think there's been a time in U.S history
where people lost so much faith in the
institutions media institutions right
now there's just so much
um skepticism which is fine but I think
to have an orderly Society you want to
have trust with your government but
there's now so many [__] people that
just don't
really trust I say welcome to the party
right well also it also made you trust
your own people less because so many
people act like they never said anything
and they're telling me this is what
pisses me off the most pops on their
neighbors for having parties outside
what pisses me off the most is all these
[__] with amnesia that act like oh I
never said that yeah I was never
paranoid I was chill and it's like no I
specifically remember you guys being
paranoid and being like so [__]
stupid I had I had a lot of friends that
were just kind of like mad that they
couldn't work so they were kind of
lashing out on me for having my studio
open which by law I was allowed to
because it was of the size that people
got mad at you guys yeah because our
studio is so small that it was allowed
to stay open by law wow so we didn't
have to shut down we were allowed to
kill grandmas by law yeah all my friends
who were working were like they were
they were pissed at me and I was like
okay fine but
hypocrisy arises when they got hired to
work in China and they went right away
wow and I'm like you were just mad at me
for being open here you're going to the
source yeah my boy you're going you're
going to get Crystal Geyser from the
bottled source
foreign